Let's put to work what we learned about arithmetic with a pretty interesting
problem. The digital camera in your smart phone takes pictures where a red
green and blue values can be any number between 0 and 355. That's 256
possibilities for red, the same for green and for blue and that's millions of
possibilities, giving you pretty big files. Now here on planet Earth that's not
a problem. But here on our rocket ship that's exploring a distant planet and it
wants to send photos back, maybe a less arrange of colors would preferably
suffice. So, I'd like to cut down this range into the much smaller range from 0
to 5. And I'd like to do that in a uniform way. What I mean was that if I look
at the interval of numbers between 0 and 255, that approximately 1 6th of them
should amount to 0. The next 1 6th to 1, the next 1 6th to 2 and so on. Here's
a way of doing that. First multiply by 6. And then divide by the length of this
interval. Then all the numbers in here will be 0, all the numbers in here will
be 1, here they will be 2 and the the last region there will be 5. Now I'll
give you a number of choices for the Java code for doing this. And I'm asking
you to pick the right one.